Next question from WhatsApp. My name is
Sayyadh Harris. I am a medical student
from India. My question is regarding the
traditional medicines advised by or done
by the prophet. Are these methods told
by the prophet legislative? And if we
believe more in modern medicine, am I
committing kuf because I'm not having
full faith in the words of the prophet.
The question posed by the brother is
that a beloved prophet has many hadith
is talking about the medicines. It's
known as Abui and the prophet has
various hadith talking about what will
cure you, what will not cure you,
talking about honey, talking black seed
and various. So the question posed by a
Muslim who a medical student that if is
it kuf if I practice something else if I
don't practice the medicine and if I
practice like maybe alopathy or the
mainstream medicine so is it k is it
wrong if I don't believe in the world of
the prophets regarding the last part of
the question is it wrong if I do not
believe in the word of the yes it is
wrong you have to believe in the word of
prophet but that doesn't mean You have
to practice that medicine also.
Practicing the medicine is not fur
because whatever the prophet told about
the medicine. If you follow it's a
sunnah. The prophet never said it is fur
that you should take honey. The prophet
spoke about the benefits of honey. The
prophet spoke about the benefit of black
seed that in this there is cure for
every disease except death. But that
doesn't mean it's a fur. It is sunnah.
It's sunnah. Prophet spoke about the
miswak that if you use the and the
prophet said if it wasn't too difficult
I would have made it fur for every
Muslim to use the before every salah but
he didn't do it so using sunnah so
whatever the prophet recommended whether
it it is nabi whether it's cupping
whether it's honey whether it's black
seed all these are sunnah it's not a f
it's not f to do it so but you saying
you You cannot say what the prophet said
is wrong. That is wrong. You cannot say
I don't believe in the hadith that is
kufur. If it's a say hadith prophet said
this and if you deny it then that is
kuf. You cannot deny that. But it's not
a must that you should follow it if
you're practicing it. Now you said
you're a doctor and there is an alopathy
medicine which may not follow the same
what the prophet has said. It's not
wrong at all because Allah says in the
Quran in surah chapter number 16 verse43
and surah am chapter number 21 verse
number 7 first
in talam if you don't know ask the
person who knowledgeable so if you get
sick who will you ask you'll ask a
doctor so now you are following the
guidance of the doctors in today's world
it may be a non-Muslim no problem and
the prophet was very clear there is
hadith in which when people were hitting
the plants
And the prophet said what are you doing?
They fit the plants again the other
plants and there used to be pollination.
The prophet said what doing don't do it.
So they didn't do it. And that year the
crop failed and then they realized that
when they used to do those action it was
mainly helping in pollination. And the
crop was good. So the prophet said these
are worldly matters. In worldly matters
it's not necessary you have to follow
everything what I say. In matters of
dean in religion yes you have to follow
him blindly. But matter of worldly
things you may or may not follow him.
It's not compulsory. So as far as
medicine is concerned there is
alternative medicine. Science has
advanced. So there's no problem at all
in you following what the modern science
says. But that doesn't mean you have to
disagree with the say hadith in which
the prophet has given treatment. You can
also use that. You can do both together.
So if you practice a general medicine or
practice alopathy medicine which is not
the same as tibi, there is no harm at
all. You're not doing a sin. But see to
it you don't criticize the hadith in
which the prophet has spoken regarding
the cure for many of the disease. Hope
that answers the question.